hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sam Sam Sam I'm gonna say
it like that every time so this game was
made in the Ludum dare thingamabob or
game gym that was going on and right
mouse button means the right choice left
mouse button means the wrong choice wait
a minute
huh where well I'm not a hundred percent
I'm not a hundred percent sure I'm down
to clown with that I don't
is this a loading screen I can't how do
i okay
number number 341 welcome to day 37 of
your service aboard the Trieste hull
pressure normal power levels normal
ventilation and life-support systems
sensory array status normal automated
navigation systems normal onboard vessel
lighting normal life-support systems
normal
recycled air quality normal light pod
status normal all systems green
calculating necessary required
information delivery processing ok I
have a question why were there scratches
in today's duty your duty is to carry
out the maintenance and ensure
consistent daily operation of the
research vessel Trieste to aid you in
your daily maintenance you will be
assisted by system automation assistance
and analysis matrix for sound the
purpose of Sam is to assist you in your
daily maintenance of the vessel as well
as oversee your ongoing mental and
physical health
if you require anything during your
daily maintenance please do not hesitate
to ask Sam
is your friend
and your friend are you Sam mad on the
marker and submit your daily help check
prior to engaging and work okay but once
again I have the same question of why
the hell were there scratches on the
inside of my little pot here literally
this scratches by it I picked up a coin
how many more coins do I need I am
healthy Oh equipment may result in
unexpected behavior Claire first hand on
the marker and submit your daily health
check this health check is important for
your daily optimal functioning all
records obtained during health scan are
completely confidential scans and
personal records will not be sold to
third parties your well-being is our
priority okay why don't I trust you Sam
oh please refrain from further damaging
equipment a shower is suggested for your
own physical and mental stability
remember hygiene is important you are
important am i I feel so special now
that a robot said that for me refused I
like being stinky this is important for
you please proceed to the shine don't
whoa to personal hygiene and cleanliness
are important for your Saturday sanity a
shower is required to function optimally
don't functions enjoy this complimentary
shop
you mean this panel that I smashed are
you talking about another one quarters
and proceed down the hall to the Oh like
you Sam I don't want to do it how do I
not do it I want to sleep in my pod
again yeah I had a funny feeling about
the scratches where can I find another
coin
alright fine then glad I got all my
complimentary showers out of the way
right what's down here any friends of
mine
it seems dark spooky
okay then whoa sorry it's a little
disorienting down here
okay do I have enough coins now I don't
know why I would need water or fire Cola
not enough coins okay maybe at the end
of the game I'll come back into my pod
and have enough coins to be able to do
what I need to do remember your work is
for the good of all the good of who
who's all I don't see anyone else here
thank you for your help and cooperation
I'd rather not how do I not cooperate
how do I not do that how do I not
progress the story forward how do I
infuriate everyone watching into getting
nothing done
fine then I'll play your game your
machine the bastard but you'll never get
the best of me you don't know who I am
you don't know the lengths I'll go to
survive it seems perfect already
what with the paint and all uh-huh
uh-huh that looks good to me
use caution while entering the live good
frame from entering your head upon the
lip doors how do i limbs caught in the
lip doors are to be abandoned immediate
mean I have a lot of questions about a
lot of things but more importantly think
the lift upstairs to the science Bay
how do i injure my head yeah I want to
refuse your order down to storage okay
didn't seem like a good left Olivia is
not the direction - upstairs you have
chosen most unwise
thank you remember Sam is your friend
uh-huh
Sam is my friend and you are Sam correct
I just want to see what happens when I'm
a bad boy I'm a naughty naughty
disobeying boy sir coin down here I'm
such a rogue with all my roguish good
looks
now behind that door there are large
winged creatures that eat their McCool
wing that's interesting on safety okay
okay
dangerous especially the left one since
it's a self-destruct button if you press
that button you will be a dead repairman
well good because frankly I've been kind
of bored of my life here push the right
button down there
the choices to be made here you have
unlocked the ending destroyed Trieste ah
we'll restart from elevator okay I want
to do that because of what happens if I
push the right button okay
Oh life to kid what happens if I don't
pick up the life Jew kit I bet I can't
escape it won't let me escape all right
fine oh if you wear that the flying
sharks will get you don't leave I'm
sorry Sam I'm not sorry at all Sam where
am I now am I in the black okay ah damn
it
ah there's four endings shut up
if you require anything during your
daily maintenance and I'm getting a soda
and submit your daily health check prior
to engaging in work huh whoo fire Cola
or water Oh fire Cola fire Cola sounds
great
okay yeah I can't fire I guess okay
evaluation composer
wait uh hang on we're all body condition
shower is suggested for your own
physical and mental stability
remember hygiene panel okay you got it
boss I'm down to clown quarters and
proceeded down the hall to the lip all
righty I got my fire Cola I submitted my
body scan apparently mine is impaired
thank you for your help and cooperation
no problem
I'm happy to do it Sam I'm in Portal
this ship will be perfect in no time I'm
just trying to do what I'm told boss I
love my job my job is the greatest job
in the world
here comes the I love my job song job
job I love my job job my job job is
great I don't know how to sing but I
love Sam Sam Sam hello Sammy Sam he she
is the best
job okay anyway I got tired of singing
so I'm just gonna try to do what I need
to do for panel one three four one one
three okay but you know who broke them
is the good question I'm looking for
coins for some strange reason tamper
with the panel I'm gonna repair the
panel repair it up I'm such a good boy
job your speedy cooperation and repair
is appreciated you are doing the right
successful please return to the leg the
lift will take you back to you of course
boss you know I wouldn't do nothing to
do nothing about that I love my job and
I love Sam I love everything about them
I love Sam's lovely voice
I love Sam's creepy innuendos I love
Sam's kind of you are a good group oh
boy thanks boss thank you yeah studies
have shown that humor increases mental
well-being would you like to hear it too
course our Chairman walks into a science
Bay looking for a panel
way buh-bah please return to your
quarters boss I don't get that one I
mean pretty good with jokes I'd like to
think but that didn't make a lot of
sense so I'm a repairman and I'm going
into a repair a panel what's uh what do
I do about that
what do about that okay you know what
that's cool thanks boss
thank you thanks boss I'm back to my
standard [ __ ] you attitude the boss is
the worst I hate Sam Sam's a loser here
comes the I hate Sam song Oh Sam sucks
Sam Sam I want to do that better you
know you are doing the right thing
repairing the access panel is in your
best interest I wouldn't ask you to do
something wrong would I
I don't know maybe you would but then I
hate you so much so here comes the I
hate Sam song Oh Sam is over sad I have
ever seen Sam is so bad and stupid and
smelly I'm once again bad singing songs
it didn't work out too well or me I'm
sorry I'm sorry too subject subject you
to my terrible terrible singing welcome
to your destination please prepare the
chords and
one how about a whole lot of [ __ ] you
and a little bit of note please do not
touch the wiring of panel 1 1 4 it's odd
because it seems like 774 can result in
catastrophic consequences haha repair
failed please return to the lift
immediately no no there nothing else I
can do here the no more explosives I
mean already Bowie hey hello I do not
please refrain from following this
staircase down huh staircases have
proven to be detrimental to the health
of penile repairs have a we would not
want you to meet the terrible fate from
flying wing in sharks is that what we's
talking about here you know what you can
eat a bag of dicks am I'm blazing my own
Trail apparently and what kind of
submarine is this doesn't make any sense
it's too deep way too deep alrighty then
don't know where I am exactly stop no
behind that door there are large winged
creatures that how about we call this
the day and head back to your place
where the hell is there is nothing done
wait a minute I don't want you missing
buttons this dangerous especially the
left one visit the self-destruct button
if you press that button
wait I'm confess old but this is the
same oh oh there's literally a button
that says there are a door that says
sharks I'm confused
there was nothing downstairs for you it
is very boring hang on please do not
touch the large buttons on the console
pressing buttons is dangerous especially
the left one since it's a self-destruct
button if you press that button you will
be a dead repairmen that was a button to
release the wild shark uh-huh
sharks are not pleasant you would not
enjoy uh-huh uh-huh
okey that doesn't make any sense it's
right there damn it how do I do
how do I do
Hey
oh okay then all right well I didn't
quite expect that but there they are so
what do I do about that is there any way
I can get to them
I mean it's bizarre but I guess it's not
the most bizarre thing I've ever seen
please go to sleep I'm watching well
that's very return to your quarters
well what happens if I don't you sassy
sue okay I'll do what you say although I
I sense some hostility in your language
may you be trying to do something to me
maybe you've got other repair men on
this ship that can fulfill my duties I
have a sneaking suspicion
that's a good anecdote thanks buddy
thanks Sam I'm good okay Wow I think
that might have been the last standing
then unlock the ending good night Wow
good night in that I'm dead great okay
so that was you into Sam okay I really
liked that because it reminded me of the
Stanley parable it'll probably a lot of
you guys got a little bit of a little
bit of something from that but that was
really cool I like that and this was
made in three days so you got to imagine
they did some good work on this so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this game down
in the description comments below and
look in the description for other cool
games like this so thanks again
everybody and as always I'll see you in
the next video